et avec le déconfinement la question du
retour au travail de l'action justice de
la cgt contre une usine de renault aux
propositions chocs de l'institut
montaigne pour rebondir
les vieilles querelles ressurgit signe
que le monde d'après n'est peut-être pas
pour tout de suite
en attendant devront nous dire adieu aux
congés payés ou rtt faudra-t-il
travailler plus pour gagner moins
on voit ça tout de suite avec notre
économie jacques sapir que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui encore via skype a bon soit
en rack vous vous êtes des cons filet
avec prudence on l'espère oui c'est
fanny bonjour avec les gestes barrières
bien entendu alors jacques ce
déconfinement on en parle c'est donc
travailler plus pour gagner moins
oui c'est la grande question du moment
stéphanie alors effectivement à écouter
ou l'institut montaigne ou encore
christian jacob le patron des
républicains
on peut penser que c'est ce qui nous
attend et en même temps vous voyez moi
aussi j'ai été contaminé par notre
président donc et en même temps nous
avons cette action en justice intentée
par la cgt qui a fait fermer l'usiné
renault de sandouville
alors tout ça a bien effectivement un
petit goût du monde d'avant dans le
monde tout après alors osaka commençons
d'abord par l'action de la cgt
comment peut-on faire faire fermer une
usine alors qu'on les rouvre un peu
partout mais stéphanie la cgt a
considéré que et la justice d'ailleurs
sur ce point lui a donné raison que les
conditions techniquement n'avaient pas
été réunies dans cette reprise de
l'activité chez renault alors au delà
d'un conflit entre syndicats
on voit très bien qu'il ya un conflit
entre la cgt et la cfdt elle compliquée
donc tout à fait réelle ya en réalité un
problème qui est plus profond en 2017 et
la ministre du travail madame muriel
pénicaud dans sa réforme du code du
travail a décidé de remplacer les divers
comités existants dans les entreprises
par des comités socio-économique trapel
l'essai ce et cce était censée fusionner
alors à la fois les anciens délégués du
personnel les comités d'hygiène et de
sécurité et le comité d'entreprise cette
réforme
très concrètement a abouti à diminuer le
poids des représentants du personnel
dans l'entreprise et dans le cas de
renault
on peut penser que si le comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité avait toujours
existé
on aurait un meilleur cadre pour la
discussion et on aurait peut-être pu
éviter d'en arriver à une action en
justice
oui c'est un exemple ou la réforme du
code du travail
loin d'améliorer le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise l'a en réalité beaucoup
compliqué alors chacun allant plus loin
ce que propose au contraire l'institut
montaigne même si c'est douloureux
évidemment à ce que cela ne ne s'impose
pas dans la situation actuelle
stéphanie oui nous sommes évidemment
dans une situation exceptionnelle
personne ne le nie le pib qui mesure la
richesse nationale va reculer d'environ
10 % peut-être plus sur l'ensemble de
l'année et personne ne nie non plus que
le plus dur soit à venir et qui pourrait
bien avoir une vague de chômeurs au
second semestre
mais qu'est ce que propose réellement
l'institut montaigne
alors tout d'abord il veut augmenter le
temps de travail pour rattraper le temps
perdu lors du confinement bon or pour
cela il dit est l'un de ceux-là je cite
le rapport le principal frein
aujourd'hui à l'augmentation du temps de
travail réside dont le surcoût que
représente l'accroissement du temps de
travail pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui la loi impose une majoration
aussi bien pour les heures
supplémentaires que pour les rachats des
jours de rtt
ce qui veut dire que l'institut
montaigne veut faire sauter le plafond
des heures supplémentaires et modifier
leurs rémunérations mais aussi
s'attaquer au principe des retraités et
des 35 heures et sur les 35 heures va
qu'il n'est pas le seul à les dire oui
tout à fait c'est fini christian jacob
le président des républicains a déclaré
lundi 11 mai donc il ya quelques jours
qu'il fallait sortir de ce qu'il appelle
le carcan des 35 heures
il n'est pas le premier et il n'est pas
le seul d'ailleurs à tenir ce genre de
discours
sammonds voilà quand on sait que les
français travaillent en réalité non
pas 35 heures mais 38 heures 10 on voit
que ce à quoi s'attaque christian jacob
c'est au paiement des heures
supplémentaires
en fait la volonté de réformer le
système des 35 heures permettrait aux
entreprises de payer les 38 heures 10
supplémentaires que font en moyenne les
salariés au même tarif que les heures
précédant c'est donc une mesure qui
entraînerait une baisse des
rémunérations
bref c'est le travailler plus pour
gagner moins
alors jacques elle désolée c'est mon
rôle là je reviens à la charge tout de
même est ce que ce n'est pas nécessaire
aujourd'hui actuellement c'est stéphanie
si nous étions dans une situation de
plein emploi
on pourrait peut-être en discuter selon
le chômage est important en france et
d'ailleurs il va augmenter dans les
semaines qui viennent
vous prenez tout simplement les
catégories a aidé de pôle emploi c'est
les gens qui sont sans emploi demandeurs
d'emploi sans emploi
nous avons d'ores et déjà 3,6 millions
de personnes sans emploi
et si on y ajoute les 770 milles
personnes qui sont employées pour moins
d'un mi-temps autrement dit moins de 20
heures par semaine contre leur volonté
on obtient 4,3 millions de personnes qui
constitue en réalité les chômeurs réels
alors même si on ne prend en compte que
les personnes qui sont strictement sans
emploi cela reste au-dessus des 11%
on le voit par exemple sur le tableau et
qui est ici présentée on le voit que
cela peu de sens de demander à ceux qui
travaillent de travailler plus quand il
y a tant de personnes qui recherchent un
emploi
c'est même en réalité assez incohérent
dans la situation actuelle
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par
là quel est votre avis alors bon arrière
pensée stéphanie sait que admettons que
l'on applique les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne ou celle de
christian jacob
qu'est-ce qui se passe la rémunération
des personnes employées baisserait
puisque c'est explicitement ce que veut
l'institut montaigne les heures
supplémentaires ne seraient plus
rémunérés au tarif normal et une partie
des rtt ne serait plus compensés et rien
n'empêcherait par ailleurs les
entreprises de faire travailler les gens
42 heures voire plus il n'y aurait donc
plus aucun effet d'appel sur les
chômeurs mais en plus la demande toutes
choses égales par ailleurs de ce trait
et en quoi cette baisse de la demande
serait un problème c'est que la baisse
de la demande
elle se cumuleraient elle se cumulera en
réalité avec la volonté et des ménages
d'épargné plus stéphanie les chansons
reggae il faut les comprendre
le confinant a été un choc psychologique
majeur pour la majorité de la population
si on regarde la chine et c'est
intéressant parce que la chine cd
confiné avant nous seuls les plus riches
ont repris leur consommation d'avant
l'épidémie les classes moyennes et
moyennes inférieures elles ont réduit
leur consommation
en réalité pour augmenter leur épargne
or si la demande baisse le niveau de
l'économie
baisse aussi d'autant plus qu'il est
illusoire de penser que dans une
situation mondiale de crise
il pourrait y avoir une forte demande
extérieure pour nos exportations
et c'est là que l'on voit se dessiner le
risque de tsunami
d'ailleurs du chômage vous savez on
considère que ce dernier augmentera
probablement de 500000 personnes d'ici
au début de cet automne seulement en cas
de crise massive de la demande nous
pourrions bien dépasser le million de
chômeurs voire peut-être même atteindre
les 2 millions de chômeurs en plus fx
est pour cette raison que vous
n'approuvez pas les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne
et oui c'est fini vous savez la
différence entre la situation post
confinement et celle de l'après guerre
en 1945 c'est que l'appareil de
production est intacte dans une france
en ruines ce qui était le cas en 1945 le
fameux retrouve ces moments de maurice
thorez
le dirigeant communiste pouvait
parfaitement se comprendre mais
aujourd'hui la question est bien plus
celle de la demande
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de la demande
des ménages
ou qu'il s'agisse de la demande publique
la véritable question qui se pose n'est
pas c'est du travail mais celle de la
relance
or et il faut quand même en parler
les projets actuels du gouvernement sont
complètement inadéquat sur ce point
prenons le prenons d'abord le plan
relance le prendre de leur relance ne
sera annoncé qu'en septembre prochain
c'est beaucoup trop tard il risque d'y
avoir d'ici la fin du mois d'août un
massacre dans les entreprises en
particulier dans les petites entreprises
durant cet été il faudrait si on était
raisonnable que ce plan soit annoncée
dès la mi juin au 1er juillet au plus
tard
et puis les sommes que veut engager le
gouvernement sont décidément trop faible
alors bruno le maire parle beaucoup des
110 milliards de prêts vu ce bar ce
qu'il oublie de dire est ce qu'on oublie
en règle générale c'est que il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'argent frais dans ses 110
milliards en fait il n'a pas plus de 45
milliards
au mieux il faudrait au moins le double
de cette somme peut-être même le triple
si on veut qu'une demande intérieure
solide et durable se substitue à la
demande étrangère qui elle alors ça on
en est sûr sera défaut alors en
conclusion jacques verrier que
l'institut mantel se trompe de cible
tout à fait c'est fanny tout à fait et
c'est bien ça le problème
ils raisonnent comme si on était face à
d'immenses destructions matérielles ou
alors comme si on manquait de
travailleurs seulement nous ne sommes
pas confrontés à l'une de ces deux
situations
du fait du chômage c'est en réalité l'un
vers ce qui se passe il faut trouver du
travail pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
en plus particulièrement pour tous ceux
qui vont perdre le leur du fait des
conséquences de confinement dans ce
contexte c'est une
c'est une politique de demandes qu'il
faut faire et pas une politique de
l'offre parce que cette politique de
l'offre qui est en réalité une
caricature de politique de l'offre est
non seulement inadéquate mais pourrait
même contribuer à aggraver de manière
tout à fait considérable
crise économique que nous allons vivre
dans les prochains mois merci jacques
sapir pour cet édito échos qui en fera
réfléchir plus d'un